[Music]
right breaking right now truth and
transparency are under assault in our
country Democrats the liberal media
there now peddling their lies and
conspiracy theories about president
Trump with impunity now it has now
reached the point where they want to
hurt the president so badly that they're
now turning on we the people the
American people and they refuse to
pursue what is truth with all the
evidence that they can muster now in
their panic they are trying to utterly
destroy the people that are exposing the
single greatest threat to the our
constitutional government in our
lifetime now here's why it has been a
year of hell for this country the media
has been lying the whole time they have
been pushing propaganda conspiracy
theories about Trump Russia collusion
even though evidence does not exist it's
a fabrication it's constructed in their
liberal media echo chamber and then
falsely repeated over and over again
they may even believe their own lives
now the media has carried out this lie
even though top ranking Democrats and
national security officials have all
said there's no collusion in case they
forgot let us do their job and remind
them the allegation of course is that
the Russians in the hacking and dumping
of documents in the election had
essentially relationships with Trump
campaign people but I'm not prepared to
say that there's proof you could take to
a jury do you agree with this conclusion
that the president has reached there was
no evidence of collusion you know we
haven't seen any of that whatsoever
George we've been looking and showing
everything that they possibly have that
has not led to that the last time we
spoke senator I asked you if you had
actually seen evidence of collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians and you said to me and I'm
quoting you now you said not at this
time has anything changed since we spoke
last well not you know it hasn't I know
we need to go soon but just to be clear
we haven't there has been no actual
evidence yet no it has not been but the
time I left I did not have seen any
smoking gun certitude evidence of
collusion no evidence no evidence and
they've been focused
perpetuating something they know is a
lie now we've been slowly uncovering a
massive American scandal that makes
Watergate the Pentagon Papers look like
minor infractions now Fox News is
reporting tonight the president Trump
has in fact reviewed the four-page
classified memo that exposes massive and
severe FISA abuses against members of
his campaign and then his incoming
cabinet and sources are telling us the
memo will in fact be released tomorrow
now as you can imagine after a year of
Lies and painting of false narrative
Democrats in the media they are now
hyperventilating and breathlessly doing
everything they can possibly do to
discredit and stop the memo from being
released what are they so afraid of
let's start with the MSNBC conspiracy
hosts in training congressman Adam
Schiff he went running to all his
liberal allies in the media like Paul
Revere claiming that the memo sent of
the White House had been quote secretly
altered and the quote material changes
were made now in shifts twisted mine
this means that the memo wouldn't be
able to be released to the public
because House rules were violated and
the media goes into full
hyperventilation mode and they were
ecstatic and they were all wrong we'll
explain that in just a second but first
just take a look at what's happening
devyn newness apparently feeling the
heat of those criticisms and according
to Adam Schiff going to the point of
making material changes in the memo the
thing has been a parade of depredations
on which is this the kind of the cherry
on top of that of that sundae now you
actually have Devin Nunez who made a
fool of himself going down to the White
House
with no information he was a courier for
Donald Trump now he's coming forward and
as you said they have cooked they have
cooked facts in a memo Devin Nunez
altered the memo that's what Adam Schiff
says not only that it's what get and
Nunez as people say he either altered it
a little or they altered it a lot which
is what Adam ships people say for
editorial reasons and to water it down
before sending it to the White House
either way okay they altered it isn't
there protocol see the echo-chamber
you got the liberal Congress
and the liberal media and they echo each
other Wow big surprise and they're wrong
Schiff is lying our own catherine
herridge reporting tonight that edits
made to the memo or for a grammar and B
clarity and additional edits the ones
that were done were requested by the FBI
to protect sources and methods and at
the request of Democrats meaning people
like Adam Schiff on the House
Intelligence Committee now this part is
very key and I hope Adams ship is
listening because he apparently was
rushing to an MSNBC interview when the
memo was being updated all of the edits
were made before the memo was sent to
the White House for review and not after
like Schiff is claiming now a typical
Democratic distraction fashion Nancy
Pelosi Chuck Schumer they're all doing
their best to disparage the memo an
attacking house Intel Committee Chairman
Devin newness and they're demanding that
newness be removed from his position and
their liberal colleagues are also
attacking the memo notice they all sound
alike one big lying echo chamber it's
amazing propaganda the release of this
memo is really reminiscent of the
darkest days of the McCarthy era with
character assassination it endangers
methods and sources of the intelligence
community all you need to understand is
that the Republicans declared war today
on our national security
well the main concern I have is that
most of the allegations in the memo are
simply not true if he were to release
that memo he would not only be
endangering our country but he would
also be violating the rules of the
Congress of the United States
you don't cherry-pick classified
information and publish it to give the
country misleading impression to protect
the president's hide all right the
liberal media is following their
commands from their Democratic allies
because they're one big group together
and all they have in the media is an
extension of what the Democrats want
they're also trying to slam the memo why
they sold freed of the memo watch this
he and his Republican allies are
preparing a frontal assault on this
country's law enforcement institutions
the Trump attack hinges on a
the Trump's Republican minions on the
House Intelligence Committee voted to
release on Monday John Kelly says he
wants everything out even if the FBI
says it's a dumb and dangerous idea
Republicans may get their memo released
today but it will not be the last shoe
to drop they go and say basically this
memo is a pack of lies and yet we are
still right now on track to have it
released this is a tipping point for our
democracy are we going to be a democracy
after today or is this going to be
demagoguery and despotism this is
something that could haunt this White
House in the months to come this is
something that will haunt this country
if we don't fix what has happened which
I'll be explaining and even disgrace
former FBI director James Comey while
he's trying to get in on the action
and tonight Comey tweeted all should
appreciate the FBI speaking up I wish
more of our leaders would but take heart
American history shows that in the long
run weasels and Liars never hold the
field so long as good people stand up
not a lot of schools or streets are
named after Joe McCarthy by the way the
last thing we need are lectures from Jim
Comey and by the way Jim just a reminder
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can and will be used
against you and Jim Comey needs to be
put under oath he needs to be questioned
and Jim I want to know why you
exonerated Hillary Clinton months before
you did the investigation before it ever
took place and Jim what do you know
about Trump hating FBI agents Peter
struck and Lisa Paige and Jim Comey what
do you know about Andrew McCabe waiting
three weeks to alert Congress about the
emails that had been found on Anthony
Weiner's laptop and by the way what did
you know and when did you know about
Hillary Clinton's paid-for dossier did
you know was phony Jim and that you know
was bought and paid for by an opposition
party candidate did you know was
presented to a FISA Court did you pay
Christopher Steele did you want to pay
Christopher steel the former British spy
that put it together with Russian
sources that he likely paid so Jim let's
cut the sanctimony what is going on
today happened on your watch and with
all due respect I don't see any streets
in the future being named after
Komi but if I was you Jim I'd be saving
these comments for your lawyers now back
to the memo that we will that we hear
will be released tomorrow sources are
telling us tonight that this is just the
tip of the iceberg the memo is only 10
to 15% of information that will be
coming out the days weeks and months
ahead tonight John Solomon of the hill
is reporting Republicans are looking to
make the case that in fact the Russia
investigation that we have been
highlighting and Special Counsel Robert
Mulder's probe were based on quote
flawed or politically tainted evidence
connected to partisans loyal to Hillary
Clinton now that would mean the entire
thing was based on Clinton bought and
paid for lies and if the media had any
ethical standards left and if they
really cared about truth if they cared
about the American people if they
believed in transparency they would have
been all over this story demanding on
behalf of the American people that the
memo be released now let's put this in a
little historical context here I want to
show you a couple of examples let's go
back remember Watergate third-rate
break-in trying to get op research from
the headquarters of the other party in a
presidential election and then you lying
cover it up a president was removed from
office and had to resign over that
here's how the media covered Watergate
then they were little different not as
partisan as today as you probably know
by now seven persons were indicted today
for trying to cover-up the Watergate
scandals overshadowing what happens to
those seven men is the more important
question what does today's development
mean for Richard Nixon for the President
of the United States is the worse now
over or only beginning the country
tonight is in the midst of what may be
the most serious constitutional crisis
in its history
history shows the American people will
put up with a great deal even when the
domain
are outrageous as they often are but
they will not put up with anyone who
claims to be or tries to be above the
law
immune to the rules applying to
everybody else it seems to be known
instinctively that if anyone acquires
that privilege it'll be the end of this
country it's Hillary above the law do we
have a dual justice system do we have
equal justice under the law compare that
coverage to what we showed you earlier
about how the media is now trying to
malign ridicule a memo detailing a major
FISA abuse against an opposition party
during a campaign this scandal in the
end will make Watergate look like a
parking ticket and members of Congress
that have seen the memo say it shocks
the conscience yet the media doesn't
want you to see it and seemingly doesn't
care as they do the bidding for the
Democratic Party like they have done for
a year pushing a false Trump Russian
narrative that has no evidence now the
media is now actively working and in
concert with the Democratic Party
they're working to prevent you the
American people from seeing what's in
the memo let the memo speak for itself
and you decide and all of this proves is
that the news media they don't seem to
care about civil liberties we do have
constitutional protections the Fourth
Amendment unreasonable search and
seizure and the media have just become
chills and hacks for the Democratic
Party they're only focused on
undermining and destroying president
Trump whatever they could possibly find
or do or make up here's another
historical comparison member the
Pentagon Papers that exposed how the
American government especially the
Lyndon Johnson administration lied to
the public about the country's
involvement in Vietnam for decades now
the New York Times and The Washington
Post at the time they fought all the way
to the US Supreme Court for the right to
publish those classified documents and
guess what they won and guess what the
truth was exposed but now the media is
doing the exact opposite they want the
memo kept secret which is pathetic and
they're doing a great disservice to you
the American people instead of pushing
for truth they're now trying to attack
anybody that is trying to expose the
biggest case of abuse of power
we have ever seen in our lifetime and
people that are trying to be transparent
and let you see the truth are under
attack by the press and the left that
has now aligned themselves there one in
unison now there's no separation between
left-wing liberal politicians and your
media no line of separation the media is
a bunch of willing accomplices and
basically propagandists desperately
trying to change the narrative they've
been wrong for an entire year here's
what they won't tell you this is what
this all comes down to the scandal
starts with Hillary Clinton
they don't care she rigged Donna Brazile
head of the DNC rigged a primary against
Bernie Sanders imagine if Donald Trump
did that in the Republican in the
Republican primary then corrupt
officials James Comey Peter struck Lisa
Paige and Andrew McCabe and probably
Loretta Lynch they put the fix in
protecting Hillary Clinton with an
exoneration before an investigation even
though we know she mishandled and
destroyed classified information and
broke the law from there Clinton took
that idea of rigging primaries and then
tried to apply it to the general
election Hillary Clinton's campaign and
the money she crawled controlled through
the DNC they spent over 12 million
dollars for what turned out to be
unverified totally false a dossier
filled with Russian lies to influence
and lie to you the American people then
this is where it gets interesting then
that Clinton bought and paid for dossier
was then taken by senior Obama
administration FBI officials not rank
and file we love them and used in part
and this is what we will learn tomorrow
to obtain a FISA warrant to spy on
members of the opposition party the
Trump campaign in other words they
politicized and weaponized America's
powerful tools of intelligence to spy on
an opposition campaign during an
election year and shredding the
Constitution in the process how do you
people in the media not care about this
and then they used it to spy on an
incoming presidential you know
transition team and then beyond that